each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so I will be talking about the deepest
programming today and for us this
programming is these things that come
from the convergence of a broad network
accessibility a rich digital environment
and the vast set of information and out
of these three things put together we
can create new things and I will try to
in the first time demonstrate the kind
of thing we are able to create today and
then in a second time i will try to show
you how we program this new things and i
think that this talk will be radically
different from what done has been saying
before because here we won't be using
type at all we will be using really
dynamic programming languages so it will
be just the other facet of of the same
thing somehow so first if we consider a
computer the evolution of computers but
not from the perspective of further
increase in performance or sing like
that but from the perspective of the
kind of entity you can deal with with
your program with your computer the
first computer were able to basically
deal with number so you were able to do
arithmetic with computers well they were
able to deal with numbers but also with
x because x has always been an ocean
related computers then if you consider
the first personal computer we were able
to deal with colors drawings sounds and
typically the only sensitive things you
can really it was really possible to do
with such machine was to play but that
was still another kind of thing we were
able to do then roughly speaking on the
very rough time table 10 years later
when we acquired / script and laser
printer we have been able to use our
personal computers for printing stuff so
it was a new kind of application we have
been able to create something of the
real life a piece of paper with
something written on it automatically
produced by the computer then one more
time 10 years after that with the rise
of internet we have been able to use our
computer for communicating computers
became an extremely powerful means of
communications so new kind of
application has been possible may also
web and so on and so forth
then where's a 1 gigawatt machine more
or less approximatively we have been
able to deal with multimedia without
computers we are now all the cameras are
digital cameras we are just listening
for electronic music's videos is the
same is not electronic and maybe one gig
earth machine was the first one that was
that you were able to use for creating a
project of your everydays life that is
you were able to use this machine for
burning cds a real object that you can
take in your hand and put in your radio
player of your car so first time we have
been able to get something and now we
are just facing something totally new
which is a new world opened by the fact
that we have computers that are not
aware of the environment if you consider
a typical machine of this new world such
as an iphone an iphone is provided with
a full of the full set of sensors you
have a compass you have a metal detector
you have a presence detector you have a
gps you have and so on and so forth and
so now because all are these new
computers are aware of what is going on
around them we will be able to create
new application and that's the kind of
application where I interested in so in
terms of computer science what are the
characteristic of this application we
want to program well first they will be
basically that fundamentally distributed
we want to run applications that run on
several computers located in different
places in the world so massively
distributed distribution and parallelism
because our application will be running
on several machine at a time and we will
have to implement synchronization and
sing like that but the specificities of
the kind of application we want to
program that they will be strongly a
taraji news because maybe we want our
application to be running at the same
time on the cloud on the grid somewhere
and maybe at the same time on your phone
so don't expect the same kind of
performance or possibilities from a grid
grid of computer i'm from your phone we
want our application to be versatile and
in precise because if you are using a
huge set of machine don't expect
everything to be reliable you will have
some fold Network breakdown and so on
and so forth so you will have to be
able to you have to be ready to program
way in this new world and then maybe the
last an important point is that we want
to program in precise application and
first that something really new before
we wanted computer applications to be
producing very precise stuff very
precise number of a real precise answer
and nowadays things has changed for
instance consider what you are doing
when you are using google or any search
engine you are asking an impress eyes
question and out of this impresses
question you receive an improvised
answer and it's exactly because it is in
precise that it is so useful if Google
was requiring something that we precise
be able to answer you very precise then
it will be totally useless so we want to
be able to deal with this kind of
imprecision and then we want our
application to be rooted in the wheel
world and I will try to demonstrate what
i mean by rooted in the wheel world with
a bunch of application and I cross my
finger I hope everything will be going
fine because I had some trouble with the
network as usual MSA so sorry excuse me
well this is the real world and this is
actually just a map of the place we are
right now and what's interesting here is
that I'm sorry I FML ok something is
mixed up but nevermind so this is where
we are yeah and the important point here
is that I am not telling my computer
that I'm here I'm asking my computer
where I am and my computer is not
necessarily provided with a GPS so the
question is are is my computer aware of
my location well actually if you do if
you want to know where you are you just
have to ask google and in general google
tells you where you are so here it's
just googles and tell me that I'm here
so that's something surprising and maybe
a little bit of frightening but um that
awaited and here on this map what you
see is that we have a whole bunch of
information such as the fact that here
we have a bank or maybe an ATM machine I
don't really know and here we have a
mailbox and that's very interesting how
do we how do we get this information and
actually it's because this application
I'm running here is based on
openstreetmap which is a collaborative
application
which means that you and I can
contribute to these applications that is
we can go and be working on the on the
street and when we cross an ATM we just
grab our phone we press a button and we
increase the OpenStreetMap data base
that now is aware that at this very
position there is an ATM so in order to
be able to create such an application
and you see the map is very precise
because you have information about
traffic lights name of the street rail
rail road and all bunch of things and
the facts what we need to be able to
create such an application is that you
and I have to be provided with devices
that are always connected to the network
always available such as you can just
grab your phones that is in your pocket
it is ready to be used and you just
press one button and because this is
connected you can go and enrich the
remote database and all this is just
transparent but in order to be able to
create such a collaborative application
you need a whole bunch of infrastructure
because you need a network you need a
reliable network you need devices
powerful enough devices all by dressing
like that and then on this map here now
displayed just three tweets which are
just small messages that are sent by by
our users that are normally show located
beside but there is something confusing
with a map so I just zoom out a little
bit and just to show the Paris Area and
now I show the tweets that are posted in
Paris and I geo locate them on this map
so this guy has sent this tweet in this
location more or less and how do we get
this information it's simply because
when you Center to it if you send it
with your phone probably your phone is
equipped with a GPS so we know where the
tweet has been emitted from and if we
don't if the tweet contain your
geolocation information such as a to FL
or something like that then we just ask
Google where is the toy FL and google
tells us where is a toy fair and we are
able to insert it with at the correct
place in the map so once again in order
to build such an application we have to
be able to reuse whole bunch of
information that are provided by
different providers
so the next application and I said I
will demonstrate is that first I have
said I want to be able to write
application rooted in the real world and
so far I have not demonstrated anything
related to the real world but just
representation of the real world it was
just a map so now i will try something
different i will grab my phone and i
will press this button and now you see
that my slides are moving according to
the move of my hand so it means that
actually my application is just a way of
what i'm doing right now so and you see
this is a really a diffuse application
because i'm using my phone and my pc and
all that is interacting so this is a an
application that is really rooted in the
physical world so let's keep going with
other example these things that now you
see everywhere on mostly in here
advertisement on the bus stop in Paris
is it something of the physical world or
is it something of the cyber world well
it's something just at the boundary
something that you use for entering the
physical oh sorry entering the cyber
world from the physical world and so if
you grab your phone and just take a
bunch of point to this QR code you will
see a whole bunch of interesting thing
with me yeah normally it should be the
side providing my slides but maybe your
phone is not powerful enough to display
my slide so maybe you are redirected to
Aniyah or maybe I got confused when i
created this QR code but you will see to
code that generate this stuff after one
so something in between the real world
and the cyber world such that
application so i imagine that most of
you have been aware of this kind of
things but i presume that some of you
are not aware of the kind of application
i will demonstrate so this is just a
small animation that shows a propagation
of the flu in europe so when we have no
information the country is left in grey
and when we have in information the
country is displaying red if there is a
huge huge true propagation and in green
otherwise so this is not very fancy at
occasion you have seen this kind of
thing a lot of time what but what is
very interesting with this application
and what is very new is that the way we
collect information has nothing to do
with actual doctors and hospital the way
we decide that there is a flu somewhere
is just by inspecting the Google logs
and actually if in a country a lot of
people are asking information about the
flu it means that the flu is in this
country and that's where we create this
application so it's just a regular
animation but computed with totally new
means so the question you may ask about
this kind of thing is first of all does
it make sense to do this kind of stuff
so well I don't know I'm in no position
to judge but the people that have
created this way of computing the flu
seems to be very serious guys and
according to our academic standards are
being able to produce a very high level
papers about that so probably it me it
has some sense then the real question is
that ok too serious but is it reliable
and you see on this graph two different
curves the blue one is a one collected
by Google and the yellow one is one
collected from the actual fact asking
doctors asking a hospital and you see
that actually the two curves matches
which means that yes just inspecting the
Google Alert is extremely valuable it
provides a real result but the
interesting point is that extracting the
blue curves you get it just like that
while creating the yellow curves you
have to go and ask doctors say so it
takes a couple of days or even a couple
of weeks so by just checking the google
logs you have an information that he is
reliable but you got it very very you
are able to get it very soon and so you
win a lot of time just checking what
Google provides
yes maybe maybe okay and so what is very
interesting for me here is that somehow
it's a proof that the web as
bootstrapped which mean which I mean by
that is that the web is just something
invented by human beings and now by the
web by just looking at itself is able to
provide new information about mankind
some somehow by just inspecting what we
are doing on the web we are able to say
yes there is a flu here which is
something just out of nowhere so the web
as bootstrap that's a good news ok so
now connected world so for this I
implemented a small demonstration which
is here which is somehow an application
that looks like what you probably use
for reading the news on your phone but I
have implemented a version here to
demonstrate and I have added some extra
features on this application so what we
can do is we can grab a newspaper such
as this one so I have slow network
connection so it will take some time and
then ok I am aware that's a title in
this French newspaper are this and that
maybe you are not very interested by
this one because it is in French so
let's check let's as a new york times ok
so we have a bunch of information and
you see here for instance that i have
the french translation of the title of
the new york times and if i'm interested
by this paper i can ask the translation
of the oh hi hope oh yeah of the all the
article here translated in french and I
cannibal tonight a translation in
spanish in Japanese in whatsoever now
imagine that time just commuting in my
car so I cannot read the newspaper so
maybe I want my phone to reach a
newspaper for me so I will click this
button
so my phone is reading my newspaper for
me so I hope that at this point you are
really confusing you really no longer
know where the application is running is
it raining on my laptop or is it raining
on my phone well actually it is running
on both well-know this application is
running on my phone actually and i can
add i can ask other stuff to this
application for instance if i'm
particularly interested in ya ear a key
I may ask this application up sorry i
press the wrong button I may ask how the
other article about this particular
subject or maybe no Iraqi yes maybe two
special i will try something else
financial crisis yes we will find
something yes ok so here are other
articles that are related to the main
subject I have just been reading before
and once again this is just a very small
application i have created just for
being able to give a demonstration not
today but it's very simple demonstration
i have been able to read myself and only
by myself so i have an application that
is able to collect newspaper relate
article that the newspaper read the
newspaper translate the newspaper and
it's just a thousand line of code or
even less than that so it just means
that we are able to reuse a lot of stuff
that are provided by others and our
whole purpose is to make this kind of
thing possible and easy to be done by
almost everyone so what about us in all
these earth as computer scientists well
this is always the same story we will be
writing programs so we will be needing
programming languages and the idea is
that for one particular application
filled probably you need one particular
programming language or a family of
programming language so if you want to
write floating-point applications then
probably you will use Fortran if you
want to program these old-fashioned
computers and maybe you will use this
old-fashioned programming language if
you want to control an airplanes this is
a sell you stuff so maybe you will
be using a dedicated programming
language such as Esther Ella here and so
the question is now you want to program
diffuse application and the game is not
to program it dividual each of these
device but what you want to do is to
program an application that embraced
them all at a time that's a new game
what language will you use and you will
be doing different steps at which we are
doing before now the question is not
ready to reduce or to implement
efficiently search algorithm or such
whatsoever now you want to do different
stuff which are you want to write
applications that collaborate you want
to aggregate information you grab from
here and there you want to reuse you
want to change you want to pervert you
want to orchestrate you want to add app
you want to just glue together things
and you need programming language for
just implementing this blue that what we
are going to do so our proposal just one
step in this direction is a new
programming language which is called hub
in that somehow helps you doing all this
kind of things so i will present hub
somehow little bit a very high level
overview of the language and then i will
show you some examples how we program
basically how we programs demonstration
I gave so far so the idea is that you
want to program in a new bit reduce
world and for that you already have the
platform which is there which is the web
so the very general idea of hub is we
will use the web as a kind of virtual
machine and what we'll do is that we
will compile hop into the technologies
of the web that is you won't have to be
using HTML explicitly but we will
compile things to HTML we will compile
to JavaScript will go by 2 etc etc so
what we are going to do so a little bit
of architecture this is a traditional
web application at future application
you have clients you I actually our web
browsers we have servers google bing
whatsoever and we have databases in Hub
we use a slightly different settings
because here we add a broker and the web
browser now contact the broker and
broker if needed we contact a remote
server so the broker is a very
convenient place where you can implement
measure you see a mash-up is typically a
collaborative application you reuse
information provided by different
servers so for instance for the
application where I was your locating
the tweet my broker was contacting
openstreetmap for the base map was
contacted Twitter for the tweet and
Google for your localizing the tweet
then for this broker sorry is also a
full fledge web server so you have
several person that can be connected to
the broker and use it as a regular web
server this broker is aware of its
environment so typically your broker is
able to communicate with your phone when
I was moving the slides at what I was
doing while your broker is able to
communicate with your eye fi system so
for instance you can grab your phone and
while raise the volume of your eye file
system or you can just say no longer
plays music in the kitchen but playing
in the living room or a thing like that
and so way the reason why the broker is
able to communicate with its environment
is either because each of this device is
also provided with a broker and to
broker can communicate or because since
in Hub we have a full-fledged
programming language we are able to
implement protocol that let the broker
communicate with these devices so
typically for communicating with an
Aleph I system we have implemented a
dedicated protocol that is a regular
protocol for communicating with high
five and so we are just able now to to
control this kind of devices so for the
application while I was moving the slide
I was just using this kind of
architecture just three peoples my
laptop here my laptop running the broker
and my phone also running a broker
communicating with my laptop so now an
important remark is that you program in
this world and actually you have
different communications and different
size of all these arrows maybe
openstreetmap is in Europe Twitter eyes
in California my phone is just close to
my pc and you don't really care about
the size of these arrows you just
program as if they were all
the same and that's the way it is that
the weight works so now programming the
web obviously there is this problem of
the difficulty of the web which is that
in order to be able to create a web
application you have to be efficient
with a whole bunch of different
programming language and this is
extremely annoying because you have to
learn on this language and also because
it's extremely difficult to have a clear
understanding of an application if it
relies on different formalism it's
difficult to debug it's difficult to
reason about it so that's something we
consider we have solved with hub because
we will be using only just one formalism
for the entire application that is you
configure the web server up to the GUI
will be implemented with just one
formalism which is happy itself so no
longer is tower that a lot of different
languages but still we are facing some
difficulties when we are writing our
location so if we make a very very short
overview of what you can expect on web
programming first we add the web 10
which was really very easy because you
had a server and a client but the entire
application was only running on the
server the only thing the client were
was able to do was just to display text
and pictures and the only interaction
with the user web just click you click
on one page and you were redirected to
another page and so on and so forth so
know very few interaction programme just
on one end very easy with a dynamic web
with a web to that 0 seems start to get
complicated because now your program is
running on two different side the server
and the client and unfortunately the two
sides are not using the same language
type minutes okay they are not using the
same language so and now you have to be
able to enforce a coherent in between an
application that uses different
formalism now if you consider sniffles
web things are even worse because you
are no longer using just one server but
a whole bunch of servers some will be
out for some time some will be malicious
and you will have to be facing the
situation so you now in the dishes web
you are live
a very dangerous world but also very
exciting well you will be able to create
new application because the fact that
you will be reusing all this information
so main characteristic of hub it's a
military TR language which means that
you will program the service and the
server-side and client-side in the same
programming language and that's why we
will be using only one formalism that
why we think it will be simpler then we
offer security by computation and then
we also start offering orchestration but
i will just present this part today so
what about the language and i will be
very very quick on that so hub is a
functional language such as hedge sharp
but a different branch of function and
language because we are strongly relying
on dynamic type checks so we do not
verify that type at compile times we
verify the metron type otherwise there
are a lot of similarities in between a
shop and a hub but help is also a
problem language for the web which means
that we will be able to reuse all the
technology of the web in hub and
actually we will be compiling hub for
instance to HTML but in hub HTML is a
value so you will be able to write
programs that will be that will
manipulate HTML as an irregular value so
I will skip this button since I am a
little bit too slow and I will just show
you some examples of some programs so
this is your first hop program here it
really looks like HTML but we have added
an extra open parenthesis in front of
each tag and we have replaced the
closing tag with the closing parenthesis
that's it the other difference of course
is that this is HTML but here we no
longer have JavaScript we have hard here
and when you want to write something
that will be executed on the clients
with respect to something executed on
the server you just add the sign here
this means that this expression will get
evaluated only when the user we click on
this table data since HTML is a value of
the language you can just manipulate all
the value and use all your iterator and
construct others is value so typically
we are able to
the same program using a list and
iterating over the list and just
constricting the table dynamically
instead of programming it statically and
hear this I variable which will be
successively bound to one two three four
five will be used on the server side in
order to create the HTML document you
want to use and on the server side when
the user we click on one better so okay
now i will assume that time you know
enough of apt in order to be able to
understand a little bit of the
implementation of the application i have
demonstrated before so this is the
implementation of the OpenStreetMap
application so the ID is that seasons up
is a full-fledged programming language
you are able to create your own tag and
typically this is a tag that i have
created which is provided by this
package and this tag actually is just a
piece of HTML document that contains d
then span and sing like that but you as
a programmer you have an abstraction and
you just see that this as new and as a
new HTML tags that you can use in your
application so now what we do is we
create a map with a certain size and
then we bound this map to valuable that
we use on the server side to create our
main page then we add a button here
where am i and when I click on that
button I asked my web browser where am I
currently and when I get this
information I use my map and I recenter
it using the information I just got so
this is the whole implementation of the
first demonstration I get so the second
demonstration the one why I was moving
my slide well on the phone I just write
a very very simple web page that it's
just listening for events which are
orientation events and when the phone
receive such an event it contacts a hot
broker and says okay have been moved and
the only thing the server will do we it
will propagate to all the clients that
are interested the fact that the phone
has moved and on my laptop what I'm
running is just I'm waiting for this
kind of events this oil tation even and
when I received it that is when my pc
received it it's just change the slide
the style of the crew
slide by just changing its orientation
and that's it that's the entire
implementation of the application where
I moved nice light so secure our code
how do i implement a QR code in hot well
that's very easy there is a nice guys
that is providing this just JavaScript
package for us this is actually a rather
complex code that I don't really
understand but it's no tree it's not
really a problem the only thing I have
to reuse is that particular function
that create a QR code and if I want to
use this JavaScript code in hub well I
have to do something like that which
means that in hope I will reuse
JavaScript and then I use any JavaScript
function or JavaScript value as if it
was a hot things there is no distinction
in between hop and JavaScript so here is
just the fact that I'm reusing the
JavaScript value and once i'm done with
this module you as a user you can grab
my module and now you have a new HTML
tag with which create a QR code and then
if i run this on my brother on my web
browser i get this QR code that's it may
be the last thing to conclude oh I have
implemented my application about the flu
propagation well if you go to this URL
you get this information by Google it's
just a stylesheet information and it's
just a propagation of the flu in Europe
so if you want to create the application
you just have to pass all this line
which is something very simple kind of
things we learned which to our office
your students you extract one line you
pass it out of this line so this is the
information related to each country yeah
out of this line you simply construct a
new URL which is this one and this URL
if you fetch the document as this URL in
returns Google will provide you and
pictures drawing the map of Europe with
all the country in different colors so
out of this URL you just get this
picture so implementing the
demonstration was just to go from one
picture to the other and that's it so
this is your all implementation of the
animation of the fruit propagation and
Europe so it's something like 15 lines
of code and I think I'm done that will
be all for me to this conclude my talk
thank you for listening